this right here is apple's brand new
magsafe charger
it's basically a very compact wireless
charger i mean
very compact except that it uses magnets
to attach to the back of the iphone 12.
and while that seems very simple
it's actually part of a huge master plan
by apple
both for the iphone 12 and future
iphones
and i personally think that max safe is
the absolute
most important feature of the iphone 12
at least in the eyes of apple so before
i explain
their master plan let me talk about how
max safe works and why it has so much
potential
by far the biggest issue with current
wireless chargers is that sometimes
if you don't get the placement perfect
it's not going to charge
and then if you don't notice you'll come
back to an iphone
that hasn't charged one bit maxsafe is
the perfect solution because the magnets
in the charger
line up perfectly to the magnets inside
of the iphone 12
giving it the most efficient charging
possible
this not only gives you a very reliable
connection
but it allows the very slim charger to
hold on by
itself so you can actually lift up your
iphone
and use it while it's wirelessly
charging
which is something you can't do with any
other wireless charger unless you lift
them both
up with both hands making it even better
maxsafe supports wireless charging up to
15 watts
twice as fast as before and while it
does support every iphone since the 8
you're gonna be limited to seven and a
half watts and you'll be missing out on
the whole point of max safe
which is the magnetic connection so
don't even bother with buying it for an
older iphone
now while this charger is a really cool
addition from apple
i think the even bigger deal is the new
mac safe accessories
the most unique new product is the max
safe wallet
which can attach to the back of a
completely naked iphone
using nothing but magnets just like you
guys are seeing
in this video from mkbhd and yes apple
did add shielding to it so that the
magnets don't mess with your credit
cards
and i actually ordered the maxsafe
wallet from my wife instead of ordering
an
actual case since it should give it some
extra drop protection
for the back of the iphone apple also
came out with a lineup of cases which
actually have mag safe magnets built
in which ensure that the magnetic
connection between the charger
and the iphone is strong enough to hold
on
through a case compared to basic cases
which will weaken the magnetic strength
between the iphone
and for example the car mount now you
might be thinking
i'm just gonna wait for a third-party
wireless magnetic charger to come out
for half the price
of this 39 mac save charger
well you might not know that the magsafe
system
built into the iphone also comes with
nfc
which checks for official magsafe
accessories
so basically if you're not using a
magsafe
branded charger you're not gonna get the
full
15 watts of charging power and you're
going to be limited to seven and a half
watts just like any other wireless
charger out there
now as far as the other mac safe charger
options there's the mac save duo from
apple which will be coming soon
and there's also the magsafe three in
one charger from belkin
and all of those are going to support 15
watts of charging now as far as
third-party cases
otterbox has already announced some new
ones for the iphone 12 that support
maxsafe and currently it seems like
accessory makers
don't have to pay apple royalties unless
it's a max safe charger
or anything more than a simple magnetic
attachment
and getting even deeper pop sockets will
also support
max safe offering a much better system
for holding onto your iphone
or a case compared to using the old
sticky adhesive method that starts to
wear off over time
so with max safe you're now going to be
able to take the pop socket off very
easily
at any time and use it with the wireless
charger so i have a feeling
that there are going to be more
accessory possibilities
coming in the future just off the top of
my head there could be a
selfie stick that uses mac safe a gimbal
for video recording that connects using
mac safe
a finger ring attachment with mac safe
a tripod that holds on using mac safe
a mac safe kickstand a magsafe belt clip
or a selfie light attachment if it
supports reverse wireless
charging all of those things and much
more are possible
and once some of those things get in the
hands of consumers
i believe that people are going to go
crazy for the iphone 12
and future iphones with mac safe support
and this finally brings us into the main
point of this video
why max safe is apple's master plan for
the iphone 12.
we all know by now that apple got rid of
the power adapter in the box of
every iphone they're selling and they
said it's to save the environment
but what if this is actually part of an
elaborate master plan
to set everyone up and get them ready
for a massive change
within the next two years yes i'm
talking about the rumors
of a completely portless iphone
and thanks to maxsafe it's now possible
now you might think that's crazy but due
to all the leaks and rumors we've been
seeing
it's clear that apple is making a
portless iphone
within the next two years and here are
the steps they absolutely needed to take
to achieve a portless iphone if you're
gonna ditch the charging port on your
iphone you need a couple of different
things
the first is to make a reliable wireless
charging solution
that supports fast charging and that's
max safe
but in order to support fast charging
you also need a power adapter
capable of 15 watt wireless charging now
there's a few
very sneaky things that apple did that
don't really make sense
until you think about the potential of a
portless iphone coming soon
apple chose to include a usbc to
lightning
cable in the box of every single iphone
12
which is very annoying since many people
still have the old
5 watt charger that uses the square
usb-a
instead this basically forces people
into buying apple's new
20 watt usb-c charging brick if they
want to use
that new cable and usb-c is conveniently
what mac safe uses yes that sucks that
the charger is another 20 bucks
but there are a couple of really great
options from amazon
like this aki charger that's only 15
bucks right now so if you want to save
some money
use the links below to buy that charger
now what's very interesting about
apple's 20 watt charging adapter is that
it's just slightly upgraded
from the 18 watt adapter that they used
to ship with apple's iphone 11 pro
which is weird because it took them
years to upgrade from the old
5 watt charger so we have to ask why
would they go through all the trouble
of slightly bumping up that power
adapter from 18 watts
to 20 watts well if you know anything
about wireless charging
you'll know that it's nowhere near as
efficient as regular
cable charging so what if 18 watts of
power on the previous
adapter wasn't enough to supply
15 watts of wireless power through the
new
magsafe charger this totally makes sense
because on the back of the max safe
chargers box
it says to plug it into a 20 watt power
adapter
which implies that you need a 20 watt
brick to get the full
15 watts of wireless charging and what's
even more interesting is that they're
shipping this 20 watt charger
not only with the new ipad air but also
the budget 329
ipad and it's also been confirmed that
the homepod mini
actually comes with the same 20 watt
charger in the box as well
so what seems like part of apple's
master plan is to load as many people
up as possible with that 20 watt charger
and if they succeed a lot of people are
gonna be ready
for a completely portless iphone because
that 20 watt charging brick
is perfect for max save charging and
what's even more interesting is that a
lot of third-party chargers like ones
from anker and aki
have recently also bumped up their 18
watt chargers
to 20 watts almost like they knew that
having 20 watts
would be very important so in the future
when apple
finally releases their portless iphone
all they have to do is
include the max save charger in the box
and a lot of people are going to be
ready to go
with the new 20 watt power adapters but
there's still
one more thing that apple needs to solve
to make a portless iphone
possible data transfer and i believe
that there are two solutions that apple
can come up with the first is apple's u1
chip
which is going into basically every
apple device and it's going to enable
super fast
in precise wireless airdrop transfer
speeds
between devices the second solution is
that apple can build
new wireless transfer technology into
the charging coil of the portless iphone
which will allow data to wirelessly
transfer
through the glass on the iphone 12 into
the max safe charger
and then into a computer basically
mimicking
a wired data connection so we know that
it's possible for apple to create
a portless iphone but why well
there is simply too much information on
this topic
to fit into this video but i am going to
give you a little hint
a portless iphone has the potential to
be the first
smartphone ever to be water resistant in
salt water and if you want to know how
that's going to be possible
subscribe right now so you don't miss
out on that video but getting back to
the awesomeness of max safe
apple was recently granted a new patent
for a smart battery case that uses
maxsafe
to both recharge your iphone and the
case
itself by using the max slave charger
and not only that but you'll be able to
place air pods on the case
to charge those as well and even better
what if they release a new airpods case
that literally attaches to the back of
your iphone
or the battery case and charges using
mac save
that and every other accessory that i
mentioned in this video
is possible thanks to macsafe and i have
a feeling
that once people see these accessories
in action
they're going to be blown away and
intrigued into upgrading
to the iphone 12 or next year's iphone
even if they initially planned on
keeping their older iphone
for much longer and that is why max safe
is apple's master plan and it doesn't
even stop at
awesome accessories the ultimate end
goal
for maxsafe is to make the portless
iphone
possible and if you're scoffing at the
idea of a portless iphone
i'm willing to bet that apple is going
to drop some huge
long-awaited features like promotion 120
hertz
and potentially slimming down the notch
and that
will be enticing enough to get people to
upgrade
despite the lack of a charging port and
that right there is apple's
magsafe master plan so there you guys go
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe because our
iphone 12 and iphone 12 pro models
are coming very soon and we're going to
be doing full comparisons
so definitely check that out and check
out one of those two videos right there
if you're interested in which iphone to
buy there's a buyer's guide there
and thanks for watching guys we'll see
you in the next video